Uh,
one of the interesting things about
urban culture the last half century is
that urban residents are increasingly
college educated,
smart people with a lot of cultural
capital.
They don't,
might not have a lot of money,
but they have had fairly good jobs and a
terrific interest in history and art and
what we could call the aesthetics of
city life.
So this made them look forward,
the kinds of cities and the areas in
cities that had the cobblestone streets,
red brick or brownstone or graystone
houses,
and a small stores that could be
converted to the interesting quality of
life that they sought.
This is very different from their
parents' generation in the fifties or
sixties of the last century because
those people often try to escape urban
life,
which they saw as closed in and you
know,
tenements and crowded streets and over
imposing monolithic office towers for
the suburbs.
A lot of those people of the parents'
generation left the cities because they
thought the cities,
we're going to be poor and degraded,
but it's their children who have
returned to cities who have confirmed
the interest of city life.
But the more of them or of us who come
to cities for the less space there is
for the low income people who have been
living in cities all along.
So it's a curious kind of culture that
develops out of great appreciation for
the authentic city that has been here
and a a tendency to impose new tastes
that drive out longtime residents and
businesses.
The idea of authenticity really comes
from Shakespeare's time and Russo's
time.
A century later when,
uh,
people began to realize that,
there,
there is such a thing as an authentic
self that could thrive in a natural or
an authentic society.
Uh,
there haven't been too many completely
authentic societies,
but from the 17th and 18th centuries,
some groups of people have tried to
absent themselves from society to go to
a rural commune,
let's say,
to found the utopia and sometimes even
to come to a,
a working class neighborhood to live
among people and live in surroundings
that they think will allow them to
create an authentic self.
So these are people who don't look for
certain kinds of fashions to demonstrate
their identity and they don't
necessarily join political groups or
social movements,
but they tried to live in a space that
they can identify with as,
uh,
an authentic space and an authentic
culture.
Sometimes it's neighborhoods like,
you know,
Bohemian districts of Paris in the late
19th century or Greenwich village,
a Bohemian district of New York in the
early 20th century.
But when those areas become two
conformist or too expensive,
those who seek an authentic life move
elsewhere so that the center of artistic
authenticity in New York moved from
Greenwich village to Brooklyn Heights in
the mid 20th century.
And also by the 1960s to the East
village,
which was not called the East village
then.
It was part of the lower east side.
But I guess an enterprising real estate
agent or developer said,
there are so many hippies living here
looking for,
you know,
for some kind of commune in the city
that I'll benefit by calling this area,
uh,
the East village and connected with the
old bohemianism of Greenwich Village.
And then by the 1990s,
the East village became very expensive,
partly because of the university
expansion nearby and partly because of
the attractiveness of,
um,
some of the,
uh,
some of the hippie and art destinations
that had been created during the 1980s.
So the center of authenticity then moved
across the East River on the,
uh,
on the subway to Williamsburg,
which then became a district of indie
music bands and bars and kind of edgy
performance spaces.
This,
this of course is a young sort of
authenticity.
It's different from the gentrification
of a more settled,
slightly older population.
So,
uh,
as,
as rents go up,
the,
the search for authenticity expands
looking for other areas of the city that
offer a kind of low down,
but truer sense of where the self can
develop.